are your kids i mean they're doing the
learning online because
mine liked it at first and then they
started to burn out on it
are they doing are your kids okay with
school online
um they are and they actually get to go
to school so it's like
you know back and forth oh that's good
that makes a big difference
yeah it breaks it up yeah we like them
going to school
yes yes my son likes online
yeah i'm about to enroll my son in the
army
just to get him out of the house you
know he doesn't know about it
and he's only 15 but i'm gonna talk to
the government and see if i can just
let's get him stationed in guam for a
while you know if you give me a twofer
you know i'm curious about something we
you talked about you mentioned your wife
alex uh alex is french right
are your kids growing up learning to
speak french are they learning it
so that they can be fluent learning they
are
they are they are fluent they are fluent
right they are fluent in french that's
that was their
their first language that's their first
language that is so i think that's very
cool myself
i think to have that kind of to have a
brain that's
that knows two languages and is learning
them that early
is incredible but is it weird
if alex and the kids are speaking french
and you're there at the table does that
get awkward
um it does it does and you know i'll
ask hey can we you know because the rule
is at the table
you know but we speak english um
but you know they slip into the french
but here's the thing
i i know a little bit more french than
i'm letting them on you know letting
them know you know they're not on to me
yet so i i
listen and you know i can pick up stuff
and i freak them out too because if
if uh i hear them talking about the food
and if my wife says something like oh
this could
use some you know mustard and i'm i'm
sitting there and i
eat and i'll go you know what i think
this could use some mustard and they're
all like oh
i think they freak out like
[Laughter]
how did she lie how did she know
[Laughter]
that's great they think you have an
amazing palette or that your extra
sensory perception